en el vídeo pasado te prometí que íbamos
a ver un ejemplo concreto de la
substitución electro física aromática
así es que eso es justo lo que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo a ver vamos a
empezar dibujando por aquí un benceno
que como la verdad no me salen tan bien
y me tardo mucho lo que vamos a hacer es
pegar uno que ya me salió bien muy bien
aquí ya está mi benceno y digamos que
está en una solución con muchísimas
moléculas de bromo okey tenemos por aquí
un bromo con sus siete electrones de
valencia 12
4 5 6 7 y tenemos por aquí otro bromo
con sus 7 electrones de valencia y
juntos estos dos bromo se están formando
una molécula de bromo este par de
electrones se está formando un enlace
entre estos dos bromo y de esta forma
los 2 bramos pueden pretender que tienen
8 electrones este cree que tiene todos
los electrones azules y este morado y
este de aquí cree que tiene todos los
electrones morados y este electrón azul
por eso les gusta estar enlazados pero
bueno digamos que además tenemos en esta
mezcla bromuro de hierro que tenemos por
aquí nuestro hierro enlazado con 3
gramos
tal cual
así y bueno yo sé que no hemos estudiado
mucho a esta molécula al bromuro de
fierro que por cierto el fierro y el
hierro son este mismo átomo no hemos
estudiado mucho esta molécula pero sí
sabemos cosas acerca de ella sabemos que
el bromo es mucho más electro negativo
que el fierro y entonces si pensamos en
los niveles de oxidación estos tres
enlaces aunque se vean como unos enlaces
covalentes simples normales como estos
bromo son más electro negativos que el
fierro entonces van a estar abrazando a
los electrones del enlace más fuerte y
por lo tanto este fierro va a tener un
número de oxidación igual a 3 entonces
este fierro tiene una carga ligeramente
positiva así es que pues no le
importaría para nada quedarse con un
electrón demás seguramente le gustaría
aceptar un electrón por allí
así es que podría llegar a actuar como
un ácido de louis
y recuerda que ya vimos por ahí que los
ácidos de louis aceptan electrones
entonces este fierro podría llegar a
actuar como un ácido ácido
louis
louis entonces este bromuro de hierro a
quien le va a quitar uno de sus
electrones pues podría llegar a suceder
que si chocara con la energía adecuada y
con el ángulo adecuado también podría
llegar a quitarle uno de sus electrones
a este bromuro no estoy diciendo que
siempre va a suceder sólo estoy diciendo
que podría llegar a suceder si estas dos
moléculas chocan de la forma correcta
así es que pues digamos que este
electrón se lo queda el fierro y
entonces lo que tenemos es por aquí un
bromo con sus puntos 3 4 5 6 7
electrones el otro bromo con sus 1 2 3 4
5 6 electrones porque acaba de perder
este que ahora se encuentra por aquí con
el fierro
que está enlazado con 3
bramos y bueno por aquí teníamos que
estos 2 bramos estaban enlazados y ahora
como de este par de electrones ahora el
fierro tiene uno de esos electrones
entonces se forma un enlace entre estos
dos átomos y como este bromo acaba de
perder un electrón entonces tiene una
carga positiva y este fierro acaba de
obtener un electrón entonces tiene una
carga negativa y ahora vamos a ver cómo
interactúa el benceno con todo esto de
aquí por lo que voy a volver a pegar un
benceno y vamos a moverlo por acá y
vamos a rotarlo de una vez y además
vamos a colorear uno de sus enlaces
dobles y vamos a dibujar sus dos
electrones
y este por acá ahora pensemos en que le
está pasando a esta molécula tenemos por
aquí un bromo que tiene una carga
positiva si de por si el bromo es súper
electro negativo y quiere todo el tiempo
abrazar a todos los electrones posibles
si tiene una carga positiva con mayor
razón abraza a todos los electrones
posibles de hecho quiere conseguir otro
electrón acomode el lugar y en la
situación correcta
imagínate cuál es el electrón con el que
más se quiere quedar pues resulta que el
electrón con el que más se quiere quedar
este bromo es este electrón claro que si
llegara directamente y se quedara con
este electrón pues estaría muy feo
porque entonces ahora este bromo tendría
una carga positiva pero si tan sólo
hubiera una forma de que este bromo
obtuviera un electrón y entonces este
bromo se pudiera quedar con este
electrón sería maravilloso
y resulta que la mezcla de moléculas que
tenemos también tenemos al benceno que
tiene estos enlaces dobles con
electrones girando a lo largo de todo el
anillo benz en icod que son muy fáciles
de quitar para unas moléculas tan
electro negativas y con carga positiva
entonces acabamos de llegar al tema de
la sustitución electro física aromática
otra vez resulta que esta molécula sería
un excelente electro filo justo por su
necesidad y habilidad de quitar
electrones ahora como vamos a hablar de
la substitución electro física aromática
entonces me parece una muy buena idea
poner a todos los hidrógenos así es que
vamos a poner a todos
los hidrógenos porque vamos a terminar
sustituyendo a uno de estos hidrógenos
entonces como esta molécula es un
excelente electro filón tal vez es
suficientemente bueno como para romper
la aro matiz y that del benceno y
llevarse a este electrón
por acá para reemplazar a este otro
electrón así es que este bromo azul se
queda con este electrón verde y de esa
forma puede soltar a este otro electrón
azul para que se lo quede el bromo
morado entonces ahora cómo se ve la
situación voy a empezar pegando un
benceno con todos sus hidrógenos y
colocándolo por acá y de una vez le
quite este enlace doble que es justo el
que acabamos de modificar en este paso
entonces qué pasa con este enlace doble
pues este electrón naranja de aquí se
queda justo en su lugar en este mismo
carbono pero el otro electrón ahora
pertenece a este bromo así es que vamos
a dibujarlo por aquí estos dos
electrones siguen formando un enlace
ahora el enlace es con este bromo azul
bromo que tiene sus 1 2 3 4 5 sus otros
6 electrones de valencia
pero aquí este carbono este carbono
perdió uno de sus electrones así es que
tiene una carga positiva se ha vuelto un
kart vocaciòn pero no es cualquier kart
vocación es un kart vocación
estabilizado por resonancia ok así es
que es suficientemente estable por lo
menos para quedarse así tal cual en el
resto del tiempo de este estado de
transición ok además la carga positiva
no se va a quedar siempre en este
carbono puede ser que este electrón
salte para acá y ahora sea este el carb
ocasión ahora qué pasa con el resto de
esta molécula pues tenemos por aquí un
bromo que tenía una carga positiva pero
que acaba de quedarse con este electrón
así es que tenemos por aquí el bromo que
ya no tiene una carga positiva que tiene
7 electrones y este electrón antes
pertenecía a este bromo y por acá
tenemos al fierro con sus 3 gramos bromo
bromo y no se nos puede olvidar que
tiene una carga negativa y aquí está el
enlace con este bromo entonces en este
proceso esta molécula le pasó un bromo
al anillo vencen y ccoo ahora el anillo
vencen y ccoo no están nada contento con
esto porque aquí tiene una carga
positiva y le gustaría muchísimo reponer
este electrón y por otro lado esta
molécula de aquí el fierro tiene una
carga negativa
así es que podría actuar como una base
perfectamente podría llegar y robarse el
protón de este hidrógeno y dejar ahí
pegado el electrón ok y estamos otra vez
en terreno del vídeo pasado de la
sustitución electrón física aromática si
te acuerdas lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado primero teníamos un electro filo
muy fuerte que en este ejemplo en
particular es esta molécula y después
teníamos una base que llegaba y se roba
uno de los protones del hidrógeno y
dejaba el electrón para que fuera a
pegarse al carbó catión y en este
ejemplo en particular esta podría ser la
base porque esta carga negativa y el
hecho de que este bromo ya no tiene una
carga positiva hace que esta molécula
actúe como una base ahora para pasar de
ser un excelente electro filo a hacer
una base esta molécula perdió este átomo
de bromo que hace que las cosas sean
completamente distintas ahora como le
hace esta molécula para llevarse
únicamente el protón del hidrógeno pues
lo que hace es algo muy inteligente es
tomar este electrón y regalárselo al
hidrógeno entonces el protón del
hidrógeno se asocia con este nuevo
electrón y suelta este electrón de aquí
que está siendo jalado por la carga
positiva del benceno y entonces el
núcleo de este hidrógeno va a tener
ahora este electrón verde que está
haciendo una pareja con él
electrón rosa por lo que se va a formar
un enlace entre el hidrógeno y este
bromo y este electrón de aquí se va a y
con este carbó catión que va a dejar de
ser un kart vocación y se va a
restablecer la aro matiz y that del
benceno y además este fierro que tenía
una carga negativa va a perder un
electrón y entonces va a tener una carga
neutra
así es que veamos ahora cómo se ve todo
voy a empezar por pegar un anillo benz
en icod que vamos a colocar por acá
bueno en realidad no es un anillo ven
cínico porque no tiene este enlace doble
y vamos a poner por aquí los hidrógenos
hidrógeno hidrógeno hidrógeno y no
podemos poner este hidrógeno porque es
justo el que se acaba de llevar esta
molécula de aquí que está actuando como
una base entonces tenemos por aquí este
átomo de bromo bromo con 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
electrones y este séptimo electrón está
en un enlace con este carbono ya ver
entonces lo que acaba de pasar es que
este fierro soltó a este electrón verde
justo en el momento en el que el núcleo
del hidrógeno se apoderó de ese electrón
entonces si por aquí está el núcleo de
ese hidrógeno este electrón ahora está
dando vueltas alrededor de ese núcleo
pero la pareja de ese electrón es uno de
los electrones de este bromo entonces
aquí está la pareja de ese electrón y
están formando un enlace y este enlace
es con este bromo
el bromo morado con 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
electrones claro que uno de sus
electrones era azul por aquí está el
fierro con sus tres átomos de bromo
bromo y antes tenía una carga negativa
pero ahora como acaba de soltar uno de
sus electrones este electrón de aquí
entonces ya no tiene ninguna carga sigue
teniendo un número de oxidación igual a
3 porque estos 3 bromo son muy electro
negativos y entonces este fierro siente
una especie de ligera carga positiva y
puede empezar la reacción con algún otro
benceno pero eso es otro asunto
por el momento el electrón que antes
giraba alrededor del núcleo del
hidrógeno este electrón de aquí fue a
dar al kart vocación de aquí y este otro
electrón de aquí se quedó en el mismo
carbono y ahora este enlace que antes
era entre este carbono y este hidrógeno
ahora es este enlace doble que era justo
el único enlace doble que faltaba para
que este anillo fuera otra vez aromático
y que no se nos olvide cuál era el punto
de este vídeo estamos justo en el
momento que acabamos de obtener el amor
q la que estábamos buscando el punto era
la broma ción del anillo vence nico y es
justo lo que tenemos aquí ok
un anillo vence nico en el cual se hizo
la sustitución de uno de sus hidrógenos
este hidrógeno por un bromo
teníamos esta molécula que tiene dos
bromo y teníamos este bromuro de fierro
tal cual como la molécula que teníamos
al final de la reacción y luego se hizo
un enlace entre estas dos moléculas este
enlace de aquí haciendo que este
compuesto de aquí se volviera un
excelente electro filo
de tal forma que pudo romper uno de
estos enlaces dobles del anillo ven
cínico pero para romperlo este excelente
electro filo tuvo que perder un átomo de
bromo que lo dejó en un estado en el que
se parece muchísimo a una base así es
que esta misma molécula pudo actuar como
una base y llevarse el núcleo del
hidrógeno
pero para hacerlo se tuvo que romper
otra vez en dos pedazos formando este
bromuro de hidrógeno y este bromuro de
cierro que está tal cual como el inicio
de la reacción ok por eso es que a este
bromuro de fierro
se le llama un catalizador porque
realmente no es uno de los reactivos de
la reacción realmente no cambia se
modifica un poco mientras está
sucediendo la reacción pero empezamos
con un bromuro de fierro y terminemos
con un bromuro de fierro el papel del
bromuro de fierro en la reacción es
solamente ayudar a que ésta ocurra y de
este lado tenemos el resultado de la
sustitución electro física aromática que
provoca la formación del benceno bueno
espero que te haya parecido muy
interesante